a new airship is the latest in aviation
technology the new blimp has new
avionics system it folds in about
additional hundred thousand cubic feet
of helium it's longer it's faster that's
bigger it's better
the old Goodyear blimp is on or 92 feet
long and the new Goodyear blimp is 246
feet long the new ships are called semi
rigid airships so they have a structure
inside the old blimps are literally a
blimp it's almost like a balloon that is
steerable right behind me is the new
Goodyear blimp which we've been in the
process of engineering and planning
works and somewhere around 2007 or so
building in particular building this
airship we start with laying fixtures on
the ground we have 13 different frame
sections into the structure we insert
tensioning cables through the frame
structure to hold the frame tight and
then from there we suspend the airship
frame from the ceiling and then from
there we take the envelope and we open
it up kind of like a big fish and just
kind of slide it's like putting your
socks on you're slightly over your foot
so we slide the envelope right over the
top of the structure and there's about
5,000 different attach points on the
envelope or it attaches to the structure
the envelope itself is a polyester
fabric and it's a polyurethane coating
that seals the layers together which is
about a 1.5 mil fabric it's very thin
almost like a sheet of tissue paper it
also makes a very good barrier for the
helium which is a very small molecule so
it's our helium barrier and then on the
outside we have the control surfaces we
had the engines we put the password
Andolan stick planted your on and after
that we put helium inside of it we also
clean the helium to were purifying clean
it the airship without helium weighs
about 19,000 pounds so in order to
maintain the helium at a very high
purity throughout the life of the
airship often we have to purify that
helium using this machine here generally
if we get purity below about 97 and a
half percent we have a significant loss
of lift and we'd like to bring that back
up as closer or even above 99% if we
possibly can usually the biggest
contaminant in the helium is moisture
water vapor so as it's light goes
through the Machine it pulls the water
vapor out and we have a 5-gallon bucket
behind it with an outflow hose and a lot
of times we'll get two or three 5-gallon
buckets full of water
the engines have vector rotating props
the airship actually the lands and takes
off like alle copter it can also kind of
hover in the air
it still can land like an airplane but
it also has the ability to hover
so with that ability to hover it can
come straight down and straight up and
then we take the airship outside and go
fly it can go 30 to 40 percent faster
than the existing balloon speed will
allow us to get to cities in less time
frame than we did with our previous
iterations it's amazing it's like
driving a really old car your your whole
life and then getting a BMW there's
something kind of mystical about it that
you seen here well that's cool it's not
something you see every day
you